Disney ha cancelado un plan de mil
millones de dólares aquí en Florida en
medio de la disputa del gigante del
entretenimiento con el gobernador del
estado el republicano de Santi es la
compañía a través de un comunicado ha
aludido a los considerables cambios
desde el anuncio del proyecto lo que ha
hecho que los responsables de Disney
pues tomaran la decisión de suspender
este plan todo eso ocurre días después
de que el Gobernador de santis firmara
una ley para que fuera el estado quien
inspeccionará el mono raílele de los
parques Disney desde hace 52 años el
sistema era supervisado por el distrito
autónomo de los parques de hecho la
compañía gozaba de una especie de
autonomía para poder regular la
distribución del agua o las carreteras
del terreno donde están construidos esos
parques pero ya de santis amenazó el año
pasado con eliminar esa autonomía
después de que Disney se opusiera
públicamente a la ley no digas que ella
aprobada por el gobernador y que prohíbe
que en las escuelas hasta los 18 años se
hable de la orientación sexual o la
identidad de género finalmente de santis
cumplió con su amenaza y se hizo cargo
del distrito de Disney una decisión que
ni siquiera entienden desde el partido
republicano aquí en Florida ya que
muchos han salido a criticar al
gobernador por esta medida dicen que eso
va en contra del capitalismo y la
libertad de cada uno en Estados Unidos
pero lo cierto es que esta noticia
también llega en un momento en el que
cada vez suena con más fuerza la
posibilidad de que ron de Santi es
presente su candidatura presidencial por
el partido republicano la semana próxima
podría hacer el anuncio de momento él no
lo confirma